We’ve only been able to record sound for
just over 150 years but in that time we have
done some amazing things with sound, and captured
some amazing historical events.
Here’s a rundown of some of the creepiest
and most chilling sounds ever recorded.
1.
Sound recording was invented in 1857 by Édouard-Léon
Scott de Martinville when he created the Phonautograph.
It was used to create the first ever sound
recording, which is believed to be the inventor
himself, singing “Au clair de la lune”
in 1860.
By today’s audio standards it’s a very
creepy sounding recording, and being over
154 years old, is an imperative piece of history.
2.
In the early 1960s the space race was on between
the United States and the Soviet Union.
The competition between the two nations was
fierce and whoever successfully made it into
space first would forever have bragging rights.
The American tragedies that ensued as a result
of their attempts to reach space are well
known.
But the Soviet Unions’ not so much.
At the time many amateur radio enthusiasts
were building home-brew radio equipment at
home that allowed them to listen into space
communication frequencies used by the two
nations during their voyages.
Two brothers in Turin, Italy named Achille
and Giovanni Judica-Cordiglia were way ahead
of most people in this field with their radio
and telecommunications equipment.
They were able to tune in to all the Soviet
Union’s space frequencies and record their
transmissions.
In May of 1961 the two brothers picked up
a transmission from a Soviet Space frequency
that chilled them to their core.
It was the voice of a female, clearly in distress.
This is a short clip of the actual recording
made by the brothers.
The woman is speaking in Russian but when
translated she is saying:
“I feel hot.
I can see a flame.
Am I going to crash?
Yes, yes, I will reenter”
And then the transmission cuts out.
Three days after the recording was made the
official Soviet news agency, TASS announced
a failed reentry of a satellite the size of
a bus.
However the launch had not been previously
announced and the satellite was never mentioned
to anyone.
To this day the Soviet Union has never acknowledged
the alleged incident and the identity of the
woman still remains completely unknown.
3.
At number 3 is a 1922 recording made by Thomas
Edison of Harry E. Humphrey.
Edison recorded it on his own invention the
phonograph, which was the very first audio
player.
The idea was to sell the recording to owners
of Edison’s phonograph so that they could
play it to their Children and experience Christmas
Joy.
But it had the opposite effect, in fact it’s
just about the most terrifying Christmas message
you will ever hear.
Here’s a short clip from the original recording:
The laugh alone is enough to put kids off
Father Christmas forever.
4.
Saturn is a source of intense radio emissions.
In 2002 when the Cassini spacecraft did a
flyby of Saturn it recorded these strange
radio emissions emanating from Saturn.
If you listen closely you can hear what appears
to be an alien voice.
It
is very hard to make out any words yet some
people believe believed they have deciphered
the message as this: “You people are urged
to drop the Earthly Impulse”.
What do you think, is it aliens or just gargled
space static?
5.
Operation Wandering Soul was an attempt by
the US military during the Vietnamese war
to scare the opposition into submission by
playing terrifying sounds through the jungle
in the dead of night.
It is the Vietnamese belief that the dead
must be buried in their homeland, or their
soul will wander aimlessly in pain and suffering.
Therefore when they heard the following sound
echoing out from the depths of the dense jungle.
They would have certainly felt a great sense
of turmoil and dread.
The US militants would often broadcast the
sound from loudspeaker systems aboard helicopters.
6.
During the Cold War for over 30 years the
shortwave radio spectrum was used by the world’s
intelligence agencies to transmit secret messages
to their spies who were stationed in enemy
countries.
These transmissions were called numbers stations
and were completely anonymous, one-way radio
transmissions across shortwave radio that
could be picked up and listened too by anyone,
using only very basic radio equipment.
Numbers stations were broadcast 24 hours a
day on very rigid schedules by various European
countries.
The broadcasts were nothing more than female
or male voices repeating a series of numbers
and letters.
The key feature of these broadcasts is that
the coded messages they contain are completely
unbreakable and can only be understood by
the select few whom are supposed to receive
the message.
Despite many attempts, nobody apart from the
intended recipient has ever been able to decode
a numbers station message.
This is a recording of a British numbers station
transmission.
And this is a German station, known by radio
enthusiasts as the Swedish Rhapsody.
It uniquely features a really creepy little
girl.
There’s a bizarre numbers station called
the “Backwards Music Station”, because
some believe it sounds like music being played
backwards.
The signal is believed to be transmitted from
both the US and UK.
The difference between this numbers station
and most others is that it never plays any
voice messages, just endless, hellish noises.
One would think that numbers stations would
have died out at the end of the Cold War around
1991.
But they are still widely used by intelligence
agencies today, to transmit messages to spies,
because shortwave radio still remains a very
reliable means of communication.
So if you tune into the right frequencies
at the right time you may hear a live broadcast
of a real numbers station.
7.
If your picture of space is a vast, silent
nothingness dotted with weird looking rocks
you would be half-wrong.
Space is silent to the human ear, but with
the right equipment you can pick up and record
vibrations in space.
This is exactly what happened when NASA’s
Voyager spacecraft recorded Jupiter’s atmosphere,
this is the sound it picked up.
It’s incredibly eerie to think that such
a sound can be made by a planet.
It sounds more like an alien tractor beam
than a big ball of gas.
The sound is actually a result of the complex
interactions of charged electromagnetic particles
in the planet’s solar winds and magnetosphere.
And you thought playing an instrument was
complicated.
8.
Speaking of space, not all space noises come
from planets.
In 1977 The Big Ear radio telescope at The
Ohio State University picked up a narrowband
radio signal from outer space that sounded
like this.
It was named the Wow signal because the man
who first spotted it on the logs circled it
in red pen and wrote Wow beside it.
But the peculiar thing about the Wow signal
is that it came from a location in outer space
that contains no planets or galaxies, a seemingly
empty area of space.
So how could a signal be transmitted from
an area of complete nothingness.
Unless it wasn’t actually empty, many people
believe the signal came from an alien spacecraft
travelling through the vast emptiness of outer
space.
To this day science still can’t explain
where the signal originated from.